[Music]
when i have the henna crown on
it's
as if people don't see the sickness as
much as they do when your head is just
bald
they just look and they see this
beautiful artwork and it's empowering
it's nice to feel almost normal again
my name is sarah walters and i'm a
professional head artist
the term henna crown is being used to
describe intricate henna designs that
are applied to the scalp following hair
loss
typically so usually people will refer
to henna crowns as being applied to
people who've gone through chemotherapy
i initially began doing henna crowns
when my mom asked me to do one for her
friend who had recently lost her hair
during chemotherapy so i agreed to do it
and it was a wonderful experience
from that point on i knew that i wanted
to continue to offer crowns for people
my name is vicki sumner
and i have stage four breast cancer
once
cancer becomes stage four and it travels
to other organs it then becomes a
terminal diagnosis and so everything we
do
from here is just trying to stay alive
i'll probably start
you know at the front maybe on this side
or this side i
originally
looked for a henna crown because i
wanted to share a message on my head
the message on the back says stage four
needs more stage four breast cancer
needs more attention for years it's been
sort of swept under the rug and we
wanted to talk about it because it's
terminal cancer
when i go in to get my henna crown it is
like a spa-like experience sarah sends
it with lavender and it's calming and
soothing and sometimes i nod off a
little bit
it takes about an hour hour and a half
and it's just relaxing and you wake up
and see the beautiful artwork that she's
come up with when you're finished
my daughter loves it when i come home
and i have the henna
she's like oh you got it again
i think that everyone is beautiful in
their own way
and i can see the beauty in these people
that come to me wanting a crown because
they're displaying a lot of strength and
resilience and fight
at the same time they're feeling maybe a
lack of confidence or you know
discomfort about the loss of their hair
and other things that they're going
through and when the crown that i do for
them gives them that boost of confidence
it's it's just a really awesome feeling
because it does make them feel a little
more beautiful i think in some cases so
pretty yay i feel glad you like it
i always believe that we should try to
make other people smile during the day
and that we should always do something
kind for the people around us
sarah is one of those people sarah's one
of those people trying to make a small
difference
to the people around her by offering the
henna crowns to people suffering from
cancer just makes the world a better
place
you